hello everybody welcome back to the Evan
n Caitlyn podcast the podcast where the
intros are made up and everything
matters everything matters like like
what like what do you mean I just intro
[Music]
everything matters everything we say I
always say that this is gonna be a fun
podcast and have I lied yet no I haven't
all the havin fun because everything you
say matters hi guys today we're gonna be
talking about FOMO the fear of missing
out if you haven't heard that acronym
acronym I feel like by explaining it it
makes us sound old mm-hmm
we are kind of old guys heard when the
kids say law it does make sense there's
a lot of acronyms I don't know what they
mean
also today like on the day that we
recorded this podcast we released a
video where we play Minecraft and I
realized that I hadn't played Minecraft
in eight years and then I had the
thought oh my gosh I wonder if there's
some eight-year-olds who like or playing
Minecraft who like like are playing it
like I played eight years ago when they
weren't even born and stuff it just
makes me feel weird it makes me feel
kind of old but I mean we're so awesome
right
awesome and kinda old talking about FOMO
and then also we're gonna be talking
about how to get the most from events
yeah some own events they're kind of
related if you're on our mind a lot oh
and then we're gonna play a game called
defend yourself which we haven't played
in a while
defend yourself motion is that our like
theme dance can one have a theme dance
okay so Keenan what was our very first
event make affair in New York that was
2017
oh wow I was a long time ago yeah I was
like two years ago
Wow
I don't know where I was going with that
so what was your like remembrance of
that cuz like it was it was actually so
long ago and we've been to now a decent
amount of events and like for me I have
a bad memory and they all kind of blend
together so I'm gonna kind of rely on
you for this so so my memories of the
very first event I I remember it being
incredibly validating like yeah we
hadn't interacted with anybody in the
maker community like in person before we
did interact with people online but we
hadn't like actually met anybody and I
think like being there and getting to
meet people that we talked to us online
or watch their videos and and all of
that it just was like very validating
because it made us feel like we were
part of it I mean the maker community is
a super welcoming community like
everyone's the best really really really
cool like you always hear about I'm
especially right now like YouTube drop
there's so much YouTube drama so many
community is the bakery community is
like the opposite of the beauty
community right now and I just want
everyone to grow we just want yeah it's
a smaller community so it's like if
anybody grows it's good for everybody
but like it really does feel like
everybody's rooting for each other so it
was super welcoming from day one and I
just remember us like we we didn't sleep
at all cuz we wanted to go to all of the
things we tried to vlog it cuz we were
like we have to record these memories we
did not know how to vlog back we do not
know how to vlog we went in with a plan
and with the style I'm just not sure if
it fit us and this still feels weird
like it feels weird
recording other people for your videos
when you're not like giving them a heads
up even though I don't feel weird when
people do it to me like everyone's
vlogging an event and I see a camera you
know I'll be like haha you know you just
kind of like waver who do whatever it
doesn't bother me at all but I feel
weird like especially recording other
content creators cuz I'm like you're a
public figure and I am recording you and
I didn't necessarily ask I just pulled
up the camera and you happen to be next
to me because it's a lot different if
you're doing a collab Coco
cuz like you come to an understanding
and like you know what the general scope
of why I feel weird about it cuz like I
said it doesn't bother me at all like if
someone's vlogging a trip I think
they're like I think we recognize that
not everyone is like us and comfortable
in that manner some people are
uncomfortable with that you know they
want more control they're on YouTube
also a lot of people like don't
necessarily talk to the camera in their
videos so it's not the same as our style
where we're just talking to the camera
all the time okay so Google matter like
our first event so just one so I think
do you remember because like we weren't
good at capturing too much footage in
the morning or in the moment so we were
like okay we're gonna have to record
talking about all of our thoughts and
stitch it together with b-roll yeah so
did we ever share that anywhere I think
bloopers of it are at the end of the
vlog well put a link to the vlog
[Music]
remember I'm pretty sure there was like
something in your nose and I was like
trying to get it out like really is that
bad unedited footage somewhere it was so
late it was like 1:00 a.m. and we were
trying to record all of our thoughts
about the entire weekend cuz really
we're gonna forget it all like almost
like falling asleep and I was like loopy
you know that like state where you get
we're like it's been you've been up so
long you're so tired but you're still
going and you're not drunk but you're
acting like you're intoxicated yeah it
was that it was that it was that bad so
we ended up having to re-record the
whole thing later when we got home so
bad yeah we've learned a lot since then
but I think that like I going into like
our very first event and what we got
from it I I think we met a lot of people
like you said it validated what we were
doing is like kind of a real thing
we formed a lot of connections with
people and I was like super exciting and
we also like we didn't go in and tending
this but we actually met with a lot of
companies yeah
really productive from a business point
of view through our first sponsors we
met at that first Maker Faire we were a
little channel and it was great and I
think that you know we also went into it
with like a slight unfair advantage
because like we are each other's team
and stuff so we always had someone to
like that's true hangout wasn't
everything I feel like I personally
because I'm I can get awkward talking to
people as I am demonstrating now with my
words that are so good but I think I
would be a lot more intimidated to do
events by myself but like so many people
do like most people that we hang out
with go on their own so it's totally
something that one can do I'm just
grateful that I got I was looking back
like man I'm glad I went like I had a
team member you will do that are going
there alone what I've noticed so this is
like intimidating to you to you guys
what a lot of people do will like find
somebody else in the community that
they're kind of friends with and say
like oh hey we should get a room
together or something
yeah going together on an air B&B with a
group and you know one benefit is you
save money because like you're going in
together on the lodging but the other
benefit is you kind of have like a
little pack to hang out this yeah you
know even if you guys like split for
parts of the day you're always gonna
like reconvene like really nice to have
someone to like have meals with you know
yeah cuz like that's that's I don't know
I'm you also show important but at least
to me they're very important and I want
to have a meal with someone yeah yeah
all right I think we had like four or
five meals one of the days on that first
maker yeah because we kept on having
meals of different groups
yeah we'll have lunch with you like at
11:00 Oh we'll have lunch with you at
2:00 we'll have a snack with you at 4:00
it was tasty too it was very tasty all
right well I think that kind of leads
into like how like why did we have so
much FOMO like after that first event I
think that we had so much like fear of
missing out because because me to
experience how awesome the first event
was and how validating it was and all
those good feelings we just talked about
and we just wanted to like keep on
rolling with that
like like keep on having the good feels
fun having the good feels and like yeah
all of the benefits that the first one
provided we were like well if we don't
go then they're going to be missing out
on that and I think that also when we
first started going to these events we
were still one of us had a full-time job
or something or we weren't that super
committed to YouTube at that point I
mean we were committed to making it
happen but we weren't fully committed in
terms of like we didn't know if it was
gonna happen
we weren't established we weren't
established I'm pretty sure we were both
working part time at the time still so
we we both had a foot in the door and
are at our jobs so yeah so I think part
of it is when you're like when you're
not fully established yet there's even
more of a sense of urgency to like
continue to grow and continue to make
connections and continue to meet
sponsors and that just adds to the FOMO
if I think one thing that helped with
reducing the fear of missing out is
realizing that you know we're gonna be
doing this for the rest of our lives
I certainly hope and that's how I see it
going that people aren't going anywhere
and there'll be more chances to go to
events like this in the future I mean
there's every year there's been an event
there's been multiple events and you
know people keep on going to them and
there will always be more chances so
just like having a little bit of
patience having a little bit of like
restraint some I think also like you
know we have had to also realize the
cost of events and not not just like the
monetary cost but like time cost and
that leads to stress
yeah and that leads to stress and so
before it was like what does it matter
if we get stressed out like we were
gonna do it and we're just gonna do all
the things and we're gonna keep up with
the videos and we're gonna do the events
and we're gonna work our jobs I'm glad
we did that movie - I am - and I think I
feel like it was the right decision for
us at that time 100% and I would advise
other people just in that starting a
colossal phase to just like do all the
things also do as much as you can if you
have the energy if you make the energy
we had the energy and and then I think
that like the thing that made me realize
that we need to slow down a little bit
it was like looking
into the future if we don't start
slowing down now we're gonna totally
burn out yeah we're very much into like
looking at things long-term and we know
like if you are gonna start slowing down
it's a lot harder if you all of a sudden
or if you're if you're doing like five
or six videos month and you go to
literally every event and you're doing
all the things and then you're just like
nope I'm done you don't want to do that
you want to like okay we'll go from five
videos a month to four to like four or
three a month and we'll go to and you
know instead of going to like 75% of all
the events we'll go to like 50% of you
can't believe that in one month we've
made five videos before Oh several you
don't remember last fall
no I blacked it out I blocked it out
eight it's five to seven videos like
three months in a row mm-hmm I just
don't understand that
I don't either because a lot of the
videos were doing really well but it was
so much more yeah I just I just don't
know cuz I feel like we're working all
the time still well we've since added a
podcast and a gaming channel and away
we're doing four videos a week now it's
not it's not going to as big of a hot
here yeah hello podcast I guess
meaningful in other ways and it's
meaningful in like the long term ways
yeah yeah yeah so we we knew we had to
start like cutting back a little bit but
they I think I think if you're starting
out again no matter what community
you're in and really whether or not
you're in that community because you're
trying to like grow in some way on
social media or as a content creator or
if you're in that community just because
you like the community you want to make
relationships and make friends and like
develop skills I think either way in the
beginning you probably gonna have more
FOMO about about things yeah all right
so but how do you think that people can
get the most from events because there's
like a lot of different events that we
could like you know talk about this in
in reference to there's like you know
all the maker events there's like
woodworking metalworking you know
cosplay and
it's like every sort of convention out
there I mean if you if you love
something there's probably a gathering
or people don't love that same thing to
even go and hang out yeah well I think
like for us the things that um helped us
get the most out of events was kind of
going with specific goals in mind cuz
otherwise I can kind of be overwhelming
like even if like so like going to the
first Maker Faire we wanted to like make
a vlog and just see everything we could
yeah and then like while we were there
our scope expanded yeah but I think like
especially if you're kind of weighing
the costs of the event like the time and
money and effort costs if you can say
like okay but this is what I want to get
out of it and it doesn't always have to
be like a business reason it can just be
like like for us a lot of our friends
like we see our other like maker YouTube
friends more than we see a lot of are
like pretty YouTube like real-life
friends and so like I one of the biggest
motivations for us going is like oh so
much gonna be there and so so is gonna
be there oh we get to see them oh we
haven't seen them in a few months
this'll be great like we get to hang out
again and so that's always a big one for
us
other times there's like a specific
company that we really want to work with
that we know is gonna have a booth there
or sponsoring the event and so it's like
ooh we're really like we've been wanting
to get a hold of them so let's like see
if we can meet them in person and
establish that personal connection and
maybe don't want to work with us you
know sometimes some of the events are
very class-based and so you can go to
learn a lot so maybe your goal is oh I
really want to learn how to you know do
Sketchup and I know April's teaching a
Sketchup class or try out a lathe or
maybe I really want to try out a lathe
and I know at this event there's gonna
be some like lathe classes you know or
forging classes or you want to learn
about Instagram from Brad and you know
all these different things yeah I think
like know what you want out of it and
then just go for it if you want to talk
to companies like don't like like get
over those fears that you have of like
pitching yourself or alike you know
Tooting your own horn
or whatever it is and just like just go
for it
yeah because then then you're gonna be
able to justify the you know time it
took to go to the event again even if
that the goal is just like I just want
to hang out with my friends that I
haven't seen in a while and I just wanna
like see all of the different things
there are or you know it's like if
you're involved in the community some
like before you go you can do a posting
like hey I'm going to this event who in
my community is also going yeah you can
see who else is going you can like forum
lunch plans or just like you know I
turned those internet connections that
you have into like more yeah real world
connections and that like helps
strengthen the whole community aspect of
all of this or like for us one thing
that has been a motivator to go to
events and we started with our second or
second event oh yeah
talking giving giving talks yeah we
wanted to start giving talks to like you
know one kind of tryout speaking about
the stuff that we do better at words
yeah we wanted to get better at words
and it also liked it especially when we
were smaller it was like it seemed like
a cool way to try to like establish
ourselves and you know and also give
back to the community I mean we give
back we had put so much thought and
effort into the into our business and
into our company and we wanted like and
I felt like we had learned a lot and
like some things that we want to share
it might be painful if people go through
them and they don't have good
experiences and it might stop them from
like you know we gave a lot of talks
about like how to start and grow your
YouTube channel and we want a channel
yeah and we want more people doing this
and I think that if people have a bad
first experience they might stop so we
want to like help people avoid those
painful things I don't know really where
I was going with us
just motivations for giving talks
motivations for giving talks yeah yeah
yeah so there's all these different
things that you can get out of events
and going in with a clear like vision of
your goals definitely helps yeah I know
why you're doing the thing know why
you're doing it yeah that's one of our
big pushes when we're talking about how
to start going
monetize your YouTube channel know why
you're doing the YouTube channel I'm
getting off-topic
yeah always know why no your purpose
no your porpoise Minds name is bubbles
and it's a dolphin
I got strange you know think it's time
for Kaitlyn what sponsor time let's get
away from the tortoises let's talk about
Squarespace
so the podcasts website Evan and Kaitlyn
podcast com is built on Squarespace if
you want to check out how beautiful a
Squarespace website looks it's so great
because it didn't take me that long it
didn't take me that long to set it up I
know it's good to go I don't need to
worry about any plugins breaking and I I
really like it it formats well on
desktop and mobile yeah yeah it's it's
so nice because like we obviously needed
a website especially does it something
like a podcast there's so many different
places people can find it but you we
didn't have like a single place to
direct people to for all that
information and those confusing was
confusing to me and other people yeah so
if you guys need a website this is
something you might be interested in
starting you can do a free trial at
Squarespace by going to Squarespace calm
and if you decide that you want to pull
the trigger and you're ready go to
Squarespace comm slash Evan and katelynn
podcast the longest vanity URL you'll
get 10% off so check them out and thank
you Squarespace thank you okay so let's
talk about events that we've gone to so
far this year because we haven't really
done any vlogs we haven't done any like
we could do it better now but like it's
also like is it worth the effort I don't
know it's also like it takes so like I'm
not it can add to the experience or it
can take away depending on what your
goals are if your goals are its document
it well and a lot of people are really
great at like like getting content while
they're at the events their Channel hey
Joel 3d printer nerd he goes to like
events and he gets like seven videos yes
yeah which blows my mind but it's great
because like people are launching new
technology new devices there goes and
talks with them about it and shows off
what's going on like
the new cutting aid edge thing so it can
be really great for that purpose yeah
but yeah so the events that we've gone
to so far this year there's been about
like one a month ish earlier in the year
went to workbench con in Atlanta if
that's a very like a smaller kind of
class-based event for makers that also
either are content creators or want to
become content creators then we went to
spring make the next month in Cleveland
which was a similar crowd a little bit
smaller of an event but they also had
lots of really cool hands-on classes
where you could learn how to
blacksmithing I mean right yeah ever
made a knife I forged a little swirly s
hook with an anvil and a hammer and then
one we just got back from was Maker
Faire Bay Area which Maker Faire is huge
and like just a crazy visual spectacle
um and probably is the widest range of
like making types but also the widest
range of people types yeah it's not just
a content creator based thing and they
were like I don't know people from I
think there's 30 different like makers
from 30 different countries around the
world which is insane and they just had
like 3d printing and like cosplay and
robot manufacturing an art and drones
dancing dancing yeah their dance battles
there's like homemade food yeah all
sorts of stuff and I don't really know
where I was going with us I think just
like summarize some of the like variety
events we've gone to but then there's
also events we've skipped to like the
main one we skipped this year and this
is the first time we've skipped an event
that we had previously gone to was make
or central yeah that's it's in the UK
which is the main reason we skipped it
we went last year because we were able
to justify the cost because we like also
at the same time did our collaboration
with Alec Steele who was living over
there at the time so we could kind of
justify the time and cost to go to the
UK but otherwise it was just too hard to
you know justify that for like a weekend
event and I know a lot of a lot of
people that we know made like bigger
trips out of it like yeah
vacation before or after but that wasn't
really something that we could tack on
so he skipped it and we like we had to
deal with the FOMO because especially
the events like prior to it everyone's
asking like oh you guys gonna make her
central you guys gonna make a central
and I kept being like I don't know and
Evan's like no deep down you knew I knew
but I was suffering from the FOMO I like
couldn't say it yet it's no funny cuz
we're like we've gotten so much better
about FOMO yeah two months ago we still
struggle yeah but I think actually I
think one of the things that made it
easier was like getting passed now maker
Central's over and even like leading up
to it the week of I was kind of like man
I'm really glad we're not going not cuz
I didn't think it would be fun like
there's like I thought it would be
awesome to meet Colin Furze there's so
many of our friends that we're gonna be
there yeah we when an event is three
months away you're like oh I'll have
time for that but when like it's the
week of and you're thinking that like if
you go it's gonna be five days gone from
your schedule or something like I don't
have five days it's like you can make
that time if you commit but it would
have it would have been special
especially because it was like the
weekend before Maker Faire yeah and we
were giving a talk at Maker Faire yeah
so we're you know very obviously
committed to going to that and yeah but
I think getting through it kind of
helped me have a perspective on the FOMO
cuz it was like okay we we didn't go and
of course it would have been fun but for
us it made sense not to and I'm glad
that we did it yeah you know yeah but
those are just really the like maker
type events that we've talked about like
there's a lot of events that we want to
go to that aren't even related to our
main channel mainly yeah I mean like
well sorry that they're related but we
just haven't gone to them yet yeah we
haven't gone to them yet and they're not
as like the ones that we've gone to are
more like broadly maker related and some
of the other ones they're kind of like
more specific so well and more broad hey
so some other ones that we've considered
going to our VidCon yeah that's like a
more general youtuber type convention
yeah although I kind of feel like it's
so broad like well I don't know if we'll
get anything out of it at being the
small size we are I mean in the grand
scheme of YouTube we're not a huge
Channel and so it's we're almost in the
top fifty thousand we're in the top
fifty thousand oh we are fast look at
that fifty thousand just 49 thousand but
yeah so that's when we thought about but
I I think we kind of keep putting it off
until until it's like we're a little bit
bigger
another thing that's the similar to that
is twitchcon that's like the more
general like twitch convention and we're
still fairly new in twitch and we're
almost at about the same rank in terms
of light switch yeah top 50,000 or so
and I think that would be fun but at the
same time we haven't fully immersed
ourselves in that yet we're just kind of
like dallying just for fun yeah yeah
twitch is still kind of like our like
side gig yeah mostly effort goes towards
YouTube there's a event in Houston a
gaming event retro Palooza so one of our
already next its June it's approaching
pretty quick there's like so many
different things
and there's all of the like cosplay oh
my god that's the one city there's
dragon Telugu Dragon Con mostly cuz
every cosplayer I've talked to when they
talk about their favorite cosplay event
its Dragon Con and like oh man we've
heard some epic stories come there epic
stories and people so committed to their
cosplay and their costume and they're
like story and fun way like not always
and I like whoa everyone takes themself
super seriously and spends like a year
in this amazing costume sometimes it's
just like people thinking of something
super hilarious and there's there's one
there's one story of like how the carpet
there was like super iconic at this
hotel that they stayed at people dressed
up as the carpet people dress up in the
carpet and they like camo
the carpet and then they lay down the
carpet and they like disappeared yeah
it's hilarious it's so good for as long
as it's taken me to finish the Wonder
Woman costume which is still like 10%
down two years like I think it would be
so fun to get really into cosplay
I just don't know how to like make
videos on it without turning the entire
video into a cosplay channel because
it's so much work it's so much work it's
so much work cause my pics oh-ho-ho and
we don't want that to like take over our
channel but like I just think it would
be so fun cuz I love dressing up for
stuff like I want to be an ekala Stella
Katelyn sent by far my jam so Kayla's
favorite time of the year yes and yeah
so that's probably the one that I'm like
most tempted to go to yeah all right so
what isn't in your favorite event we've
gone to so far mmm I mean it might be
like that very first Maker Faire I think
so too you know and I don't know if it
would have been whatever the first event
the probably would've been the very
first event was and I also it's kind of
like our first two events our very first
Maker Faire in our very first work
because that was the very first place we
talked and that like really helped
legitimize us in our own brain in our
own brains yeah and it's like the more
serious you take yourself the more
serious you are very serious are you
serious face you try not to smile I'm
not good at it okay yeah I think I think
those are my first so yes it's it's not
even really like necessarily tied to the
events specifically I think it's just
like the memories we associate with them
but I think it's cool that like the
events like this can be very informative
yeah you know yeah I think the one I'm
most excited to go to is I can't really
choose between the cosplay and then like
a general YouTube thing because I think
the general YouTube thing might be kind
of fun to kind of expand our like
network and our vision of like our
channel and our future and I think that
might be really exciting but also
cosplays
like it's just a lot of fun yeah Cosmo
seems like a lot of fun excited by
someone's and for the reasons going to a
YouTube event like a more general
YouTube event I think like I mean of
course there are people I would love to
meet mmm but I probably wouldn't get a
chance to meet but just like people who
channels I love that wouldn't be at
maker events yeah but I do think it
would be super interesting every now and
then we get a chance to talk to someone
who's a youtuber that is not in the
maker community and their approach to
everything is so different it's so
different so interesting because a lot
of the makers you know everyone is
different but it's all within a similar
framework most like dealing with
sponsors is different dealing with
comments is different you know dealing
with the community the thumbnail the
title like how everything is structured
in a way it's it's so different and so
much thought goes into YouTube for
everyone yeah but it's just like
different brain pathways we could get
into it so I want to get into it you
know it is time for game time friend
yourself defend yourself
[Music]
alright guys so we have a planter pot of
statement that we're gonna have to
defend so we each wrote an equal number
of statements and we're gonna mix it up
don't draw it yet and we take turns
drawing the card we don't know if we're
gonna get one that we wrote or the other
person wrote and then the person who
draws it has to defend that statement
the other person has to like be against
it alright okay there's one that I wrote
so I can easily defend this Diablo 2 is
the best game ever
it's the best absolute best the best
game in the entire world pretty much
yeah best game in the world but there's
not even like good puzzles to solve if
they're puzzle solving an important part
of games yeah I mean you have to like
like how to defeat someone is a puzzle
in and of itself you know it's like you
have to like figure out how to move how
to do things you know and like come on
think about all the games you played how
many hours have you put into Diablo - I
don't think hours in is necessarily a
measure of goodness maybe it's just a
measure of like unnecessarily
unnecessary difficulty ah but did you
ever think that is unnecessarily
difficult yes finish table - no because
it's not the best game in the world
oh it's totally the basket hablo 3 I
felt like you know if you look at a
chart of how much time has gone into a
game Diablo 2 won't be the highest no I
was thinking World of Warcraft probably
yeah wow I was like oh like it's been
around for so long people put so many
hours and do it you know it's like like
I'm already struggling to defend it on
my own side but like it's so hard to
ever choose like a best anything it is I
mean I I do have faith so wait I have a
question okay we're getting off topic is
Diablo 2 your favorite game I just like
have such fond memories of it and uh you
know I wrote this question yesterday and
it's interesting because it's been a day
I've had like reflected on it well just
by instinct you know I just like have
wrote it down yeah you wrote
superfast but it's so interesting
because I'm like looking back at why I
think it's my most like nostalgic like
deeply rooted game in my brain and
experience or something I think it's
because of the time of my life that I
that I played that game it I remember
like the music I was listening to while
I played Diablo yeah but I think it's
just like I had the time to like really
fall into that game yeah I just like
completely experienced it I didn't want
to do anything else I was just like
doing it a hundred percent with all of
my attention and I was so satisfied with
it and I think that like part of the
reason why I love it is for that
nostalgia factor yeah in a way like I
could probably boot up Diablo 2 right
now and play it and be completely happy
I can hear the music right and like it's
the game that I think of so much and I
want to go back into and so I think it's
more accurate like Diablo 2 is the game
I want to go back and play the most well
I can't really argue what the game that
you want to go but it's not the best
game ever
okay so like if you had to defend
something what would be your best game
ever
zelda ocarina of time okay why is it the
best game ever cuz it's great story the
graphics even though by today's
standards they're nothing crazy
they were beautiful there was music
there was music everybody best game ever
what what video game song is the song we
sing the most tenten tenten tenten
tenten tenten tenten tenten yeah
[Laughter]
physically pushing you away from the mic
attempting to I'm rolling myself back
okay no but what that's it that's the
game we seeing the most what's okay then
you know what I didn't finish that game
no time seriously seriously didn't like
go through the crumbling quit the
crumbling craft I don't think I did oh
my god
I know I played it but I just don't
remember finishing it seconds I can see
not finishing Diablo 2 because it
requires a lot of you know just kind of
like leveling up and it's easier to me
it's easier to get brain I never ground
I never like played the same place to
get into getting in I just had to it
because I was cautious and I liked to be
at a proper level before I fight the
boss I don't do that anymore but at the
time you know I have a time okay yeah
but but Zelda it's not that long of a
game and there's like specific goals all
the temples do you remember where you
got to do you do the desert temple this
game you know how bad I dream it so that
like you can be a proper person I'm not
a proper version I have not finished I'm
not at the game anymore taken okay my
turn
yeah I don't know if I'm gonna draw one
of yous are one of mine well I guess
kind of the point okay okay this is one
of mine Harry Potter characters should
have all been cats the book I was
reading here shocked imagine everybody
it's a world of cats it's only cats only
casted the entire world is cat he who
must not be mewed her meow any Harry
Potter but like it's it's like
okay I can imagine Haggard is a big guy
I know some what are those like giant
giant like super like the Russian like
Maine [ __ ] Maine [ __ ] oh yeah those big
boys but just like but like has there
ever been a movie that's like CG or like
animated cats that's been good defend
yourself oh yeah but but it's not about
the CG it's not the story the story okay
how but then if they change the story
would it even be Harry Potter anymore no
no they wouldn't change the story story
but there's like cat wizards and cat
muggles just better
it's just better not now now kittens
would be cute some would be kittens I
mean like um you know the younger people
would be more kitten like tell me how I
would be visually would be live-action
would it be 3d animated it were to be
drawn I had mainly thought about the
books it you know so funny this is the
best thing I mainly thought of the books
Harry Potter both cats they wouldn't
have to change anything really
he's imagine them as cats and then
that's it
you can have Harry Potter has cast now
you're gonna hear yeah mind blown oh my
god yeah Hermione is really fluffy yeah
Ron's ronzo like orange tabby yep
oh my god my dream is true but Arizona
how different it be that's not the point
for cats all right I don't know how to
fight with you you're in your own world
but I just don't see it okay I'm okay
now I will admit the best animated cat
or the best cat movie there is
Aristocats Aristocats is a good movie
Aristocats is a great movie it's the
best cat movie no no I have a cat movie
I like a lot better
what's that cats don't dance I haven't
finished
Oh No Caleb finally got all these
shocking like came out when a bunch of
Disney movies are coming up but it's not
Disney it's like a knockoff no it's like
Warner Brothers like a main thing but
like the the animation style cats don't
dance look at the animation style was so
different and it like the humor was so
good it was just like there's so much
more movement in the animation I have
never seen this movie I've never heard
about it oh my gosh it's so good there's
an elephant yeah there's a lot of
animals they're all in showbiz yeah and
it's like in a world where animals are
trying to hold on to showbiz jobs but
like humans are taking them and animals
are being like directed to like animal
roles oh not main character roles little
girl she's basically like honey boo boo
before there was honey boo boo oh yeah
curse her foreshadowing yeah there's a
really good movie okay well maybe we'll
have to add that to our movies to watch
in five years all right I will now
defend myself I hope you get one of mine
I want us to get each other's cuz I want
that too like I keep on picking up the
same ones I'm trying to cheat the system
and I'm failing okay this one's a year's
Mullis are the most superior hairstyle
they don't get in your way
you look super rad and you look super
rad I feel like I feel like mullets we
just kind of make the back here neck hot
right but what have you live in a cold
climate and let that's your most
sensitive space and you're always
wouldn't you wear a scarf because the
scarf you can take on and off but a
mullet you can put a mole it up in a
ponytail a MOLLE tail a MOLLE tail and
look extra fashionable you know what
everything goes through cycles the
mullets had its heyday in the past and
now it's coming back it's about time to
bring molds back hash tag bring back but
I don't think that makes it the most
superior hairstyle I think it's the most
super
hairstyle would be one that never went
away no you want to be trendy you want
to stand out from the crowd so that
never goes away you can never be
different you could never stand out
mullets are forever
hashtag bullets are forever I don't know
but I think like a mullet also requires
a decent mount of styling right you have
to like fluff up the top and then like
straighten the bottom it's so much or
like curl the bottom does this go for
just throw some moves in there and
you're gonna do some mousse will solve
this if your hairstyle okay name a
better hairstyle um mine no more I'll be
so attracted to you if you ever had a
mullet
we both had mullets Oh would rule the
internet too good of a thing I'm too
good of a defender imagine if we were
like the married couple with mullets
channel yep we just need to rename it
married with mullets hashtag married
with mullets okay okay you know what's
weird I almost wrote this what we
weren't this isn't even something we
were talking about
no okay the beach vacations are the best
and this is I'm just gonna be upfront
about this this is gonna be hard to
defend but okay so you think beach
vacation what about mountains what about
the majesty of like cliffs and stuff
you can't go hiking on a beach oh we
went hiking on a beach in Thailand you
can't always go hiking on a beach yeah
but you can't always go hiking on
Mountains either a lot of mountains are
very dangerous beaches are great for the
entire family whether you're a baby or
someone who's very old you can enjoy a
beach and everyone in between and you
can be lazy or you can be active what's
what's the condition where you can't go
in the Sun I'm not gonna tell you
because then you can use that as an
argument people that have that they
should just you like they know what's up
they can go for a vacation in Washington
with the rain you know you can have a
rain vacation rain can be
- I feel like you're just making
argument for not being outside not
necessarily not yeah okay you know you
should do get everyone together like you
know like rent a giant house put video
games everywhere imagine like a five day
land party and everyone's just playing
games you just order pizza in everyone
just like chills and like lives like
their best memories of their like
childhoods through video games you know
that'd be pretty great but you know and
make it better if that house was on a
beach you could also all go to the beach
but then a distract from the video game
no you need a break from that you need
it you need to set up you need to get
some sunlight but then you're gonna get
sand in your keyboard you don't take the
keyword with you I do you don't order
the beach Cuba keyboard you can't argue
this because you wrote it and I know
that we both love beach vacations I do a
lot of other vacations too but I think
beach vacations are the best if if you
want an easy vacation or if you're with
a group because when you're doing other
vacations like if you're in the
mountains or stuff it's a lot harder to
organize a group to all go hiking on the
same hike that's the same level
difficulty in the same location at the
same time of day but like beach
vacations everyone's gone to a beach not
everyone has gone skiing because not
everyone wants to go skiing because it's
not as universally liked everyone has
gone to the beach but not everyone has
kinda Mount Everest
well yes and education I hear it's a hot
new trend coming up in 2020
everyone's hopping on the the Herpa
surfer wagon are you are you arguing
that Mount Everest is the best the top
is the tip top vacation you can't get a
higher vacation than that then you go to
the Marianas Trench that's better than a
beach just go in a submarine to the
bottom of the ocean and sea creatures
that no one has seen before in the world
you're the very first person to
experience that boom
I think universally by my own experience
when when someone when you think of a
vacation postcard that's someone sending
what do you picture a beach there's a
single palm tree there's a lone beach
chair and there's a sunset Marianas
Trench unknown sea creatures through
grainy cameras completely this one
because my argument was so boss I don't
know okay I got yours okay that's more
fun when we get each other I'm okay with
us achieving a little bit I'm gonna burn
this I'm gonna burn this ramen with
melted American cheese is a great idea
you can have two of the like best things
in the world ramen delicious American
cheese delicious who hasn't thought of
like you know you're eating a grilled
cheese sandwich and you're like mmm this
cheese is great but you know be better
than a buttery toast around the cheese
ramen God be delicious I've thought that
every time counter point please
disgusting you're an abomination I can't
believe you would think such a thing you
know what have you ever tried it no
because I'm a sane human don't knock it
till you've tried it
have you tried it in my dreams every
night in my dreams I see ramen with
melted cheese that song right there how
can you fight that it's beautiful like
okay just imagine for a second you have
salty semi soupy ramen noodles you get
that you get the soup out you Dre that
you drew are you just making macaroni
and cheese with ramen how can you get
better than that macaroni and cheese
okay I feel like this is unfair I did
pretty good I did pretty good defending
myself
okay what's the backstory a few things
it's multi-tiered okay so I recently
started falling a subreddit called food
hacks no cuz it was suggested to me on
reddit and I like the top few I was like
oh that's okay yeah maybe I'll follow
this what were some of the top ones do
you remember I have no idea
then leave an impression one that caught
my eye was adding American cheese to
ramen this is a real suggestion did
people in the like comments like totally
trash it okay wow this is a good idea
they said it was good but I also was
listening to reply all yeah episode
recently and they were talking about how
I think I don't know some like
relatively established yeah like new
source or magazine or something but
every now and then have these like
recipe suggestions that would outrage
the internet so the first one was like
make guacamole but add peas I want to
find someone I know right it's like
seemingly real suggestions they had like
a full recipe and pictures all there so
it was it was it intentional trolling no
I don't know I don't know one knows as
far as from what I could gather from the
episode no one knows but another one was
ramen with melted American cheese and I
was like oh my god it comes back maybe
that's where that food hack got it from
or maybe it's the other way around
I don't know but oh man we're gonna have
wok for dinner and I'm just gonna think
about peas mixed in there like the
flavor profiles don't go together at all
like but lime on peas you know ramen
with cheese sounds more appealing than
wok with peas yeah yeah I actually like
I you could maybe make that work if you
were craving mac and cheese and you
didn't have anything you know I'm an
enemy I would try a bite of it without
without that much judgment but my guess
is like using my predictive logic here
I'm not sure if it'd be the best okay so
by the way our life hack for ramen you
make ramen with very little liquid it
leaves a more strong flavor I just do
water for the liquid you do a little bit
of water but a little bit of soy sauce
and you do a little bit of red pepper
flakes like red pepper in there and then
so it's not soupy at all like all the
liquids absorbed and there's
some crunchy bits left yeah old water
basically boils out it all boils out um
you still use like the little like
flavor packet and stuff but it's more
concentrated you don't lose all the
flavor in the soup it's delicious and we
have it with edamame on the side so that
we feel healthy in air quotes thank you
defend yourself read it and weep
Spaceballs is the best movie ever
I agree thanks for saying that hahaha
good job you win okay my kung pao heart
okay I'll actually I'll actually fight
it you know what
Spaceballs you can't watch that with the
whole movie they say curse words in
there yeah but I feel like some of the
best movies in the world have curse
words and that doesn't mean that they're
not the best movies if you look at most
critically acclaimed movies movies that
win Oscars a lot of them are cursing
cursing is not something that makes the
movie less good yeah but like what does
does like Spaceballs have a perfect
story arc no yes it does
okay you're right good argument there's
so many good things it mixes humor it
makes sighs romance romance it's it's
really got everything it's really got
everything yo he also has everything
Kaylin kung pao comes out you can fight
me
oh no Spaceballs is so much better it's
more quotable than I can't drink coffee
without saying hot too hot you have to
like you know intentionally training a
young boy to fight incorrectly how like
pinnacle of humor yes let's switch I
want to defend Spaceballs cuz it is the
best you can defend compound cuz like I
admit come house wonderful
I admit Spaceballs is okay no no
Spaceballs is better than kung pao
because like it just like gets stuck in
your head you wash it and you just like
keep on thinking about like you know
that intro that goes on for a little bit
too long ooh that's some good humor I
know that scene where he's that we're
the chosen one is running front like to
the camera from the distance and he
keeps the camera keeps showing the same
scene because it goes back okay we match
we equally match we both have a scene
like that yep okay puns no the pass the
puns no spaceball puns like we've been
jammed in this literal Jam pinnacle of
humor right there okay may
Spaceballs might have it slightly more
in the pun region yeah a very like
common form of humor around the time was
the randomness back earth it factor
think of the internet yeah well think of
I need go for Chuck's hair voice like
think of a random thing that's funny
yeah but like do that is it aged well
are people still doing just random
things just to be random yes name some
reason movies things okay what about
that the scene in space Falls where that
guy was making all the noises with like
his mouth instead of the computer making
it like that
you know that takes skill that's there's
some like legitimate skill and space
balls taking an old actual kung-fu movie
and inserting actors into it interacting
with people that aren't there and making
it believable mm-hmm great special
effects no no no compound did have a
good twist a great twist had a great
twist don't a spoiler for anyone who
hasn't watched it spoil it yeah okay how
about this they're both wonderful movies
both wonderful movies it's hard to know
it yep yep all right guys well hey thank
you so much oh no thing of the week
think of the week we always forget think
of the week cuz we get really caught
in the game cue the music
alright so my thing of the week is I
mean the thing I'm actually obsessed
with I don't have any like thing to
point to yet but ultra mobile PCs you
NPCs like little netbooks like really
really small computers like 7 inch 8
inch computers
I am literally obsessed with that I'm
like going down the rabbit hole I will
find it I'll update you if I find the
right one but like that's what I'm
obsessed with you've been obsessed with
this for years years years years like
many many years I had a netbook way back
in the day and I loved that thing we
used to play Mario Kart on it in dance
class oh so good it was like it was like
a low powered Atom processor which like
really stinks now but I just love the
idea of having a full computer even this
carry around Oh like super mobile and
I've always wanted one you can fit in
your pocket that's like the dream for me
to have a legit computer that I can fit
in my pocket I like bigger pockets feel
like a like 11 inch wide like cargo
pants pocket we'll just make a custom
one for the channel pocket computer ok
but my legit thing of the week like a
real thing that I can point to is we got
a 16 X battery charger it can charge 16
double-a 16 or 16 triple-a and like what
that does for us on like a day-to-day
week-to-week basis this huge lets us
charge all like you know because we have
lav mics we have all this technology
game controllers it's just like let's
just have all the batteries we need
charged all the time and you'd think
that's dumb you don't need that you only
need like with that for one that
everyone has that only charges for about
it at once we sometimes need to charge
like 8 to 12 batteries a day and
remembering to go back and swap them out
you don't do that
we're very forgetful like even Caitlyn
who's wonderful at murmuring stuff
things that's just a small detail that
can get overlooked so yeah I don't know
it's a game changer for us we no longer
have to Salvage batteries from like
video game controllers and stuff because
we need them in a lav mic yeah and vice
versa that's great it's great yeah
what's your thing of the week well I
mean you just did like 2
of the week that you could and like one
of them you could link to mine I can't
really link to it's just something I
really like what's that
milk tea mm-hmm we had milk tea
yesterday we did as which okay milk tea
is like it's not just to you with milk
isn't it just poke do you love tea well
it's not it's not just like making tea
and putting a little bit of milk in it
it's different and I don't know how to
make it but it's like really strong tea
flavor yet equally strong milkiness
without diluting the tea and I know I
can just look up a recipe but I haven't
done it yet what if it is like like boil
milk and put tea in it but like I've
tried doing that for like chai tea yeah
lattes and it is good but it's hard to
not like once it's like oh yeah like
that's all like I'm on the top of the
milk and like how do you not have that I
don't know maybe it's different when
it's iced because like you can just like
skim all the milk stuff off the top and
then you're left with like the look it
up on YouTube with everyone else it's
like how do you note how to do these
things we always look it up on YouTube
I'm sure there's recipe out there I know
but I'm also like is it like a team a we
need to like go to a certain market to
get it I don't know I'm just I don't
have answers for you I'm just sharing
what I really like and I've had it like
twice this week which is more than I
normally get to have it and I want it
right now all right guys
tune in next time for the stunning
conclusion of the milk tea saga thank
you so much for joining and thank you
everyone who further like continued
listens reviews we see them coming in it
really makes us happy and makes our
hearts blow blowing right now if you're
watching you can still not see it
because we're wearing clothes okay
[Applause]
[Music]